this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happened you bad
[__] it's Wednesday the 28th of
September the joint is brought to you by
this plate looking for something to
cover up that hole in your wall this
plate is a cool new metal poster you'll
want in every room they got millions of
designs available featuring gaming
movies and Comics featuring officially
licensed designs from Star Wars Netflix
and many more they sent me a Bruce Lee
one that is [__] smoking and only
takes 20 seconds to hang a display no
power tools no damages no frustrations
once you mount one you can switch it out
in a new plate and a flash with everyone
you buy this plate plants a tree click
the link in the description to see some
my favorite disc plates and save up to
29 percent get 25 off when you buy one
or two get 29 off when you buy three or
more discounts will automatically be
applied to your cart when you click the
link or use code Joey j-o-e-y Joey when
you visit display.com that's
displayed.com code Joey or check the
link for show notes the joint is also
brought to you by liquid IV listen
liquid IV is tremendous you got no time
to play no Stakes no pressure just fun
few
eight with liquid IV for hydrations
that's two times faster than water alone
because life's better when you're
hydrated liquid ID comes in 10
refreshing flavors my favorites concord
grape the tropical punch the Cherry is
off the [__] chain and the acai is
tremendous also what makes liquid IV so
effective is cellular transport
technology designed to enhance
absorption of water into the bloodstream
liquid IV contains five essential
vitamins B3 B5 B6 B12 they got all the
B's you know what I'm saying
electrolytes more three times the
electrolytes in sports drinks so do me a
favor grab your liquid IV in bulk
nationwide at Costco or I'm Gonna Get
You 15 off when you go to liquid iv.com
use code Joey again liquid ib.com use
code Joey at checkout that's 15 off
anything you order from liquid IV just
put Joey in checkout and the joint is
also brought to you by Jesus [__]
Christ draftking Sportsbook an official
sports betting partner of the NFL we're
talking touchdowns biting in the necks
we're talking everything new customers
you bet five dollars on any NFL team to
win and you get 200 and free bets and
this is the week to do it tomorrow all
night you got the Buffalo Bills against
the [__] Cincinnati Bengals
Cincinnati Bengals are giving an
undefeated team three and a half what
the [__] do you think is going on there
I just gave you a winner cocktuckers
it's not enough everyone can boost their
winnings with DraftKings stepped up same
game parlays the more legs you add the
more money you get they got profit boost
you got the UFC and you got baseball
playoffs who's better than DraftKings
nobody [__] use promo code Joey
and download the DraftKings Sportsbook
app right now or the fantasy app that
giving away a million dollars every
[__] week in cash prizes and you're
sitting there scratching your head
thinking about where you're gonna go eat
lunch you [__] download the drift
King sports book app use code Joey only
at DraftKings Sportsbook an official
sports betting partner of the NFL
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details now go
download DraftKings and let's get this
[__] party started
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
Joy
[Music]
foreign
welcome to the [__] joint you bad
[__] it's Wednesday the 28th
the guest today is the [__] Man of
Steel
this guy is a [__] human success
story
Mr victoro all right that's it that's
close enough
[__] around that's okay well I'm used to
it I'm honored to be here you look
[__] great to have you thank you what
happened to your chin I can't
it's like it was a [__] ingrown head
it went from being negro hair
that I cut with a razor that became a
boil and then became a staph infection
wow when they threw the antibiotics on
it it didn't do dick to it so I did a
biopsy and I'm waiting for the results
I'm sitting here today and my doctor
lives around the corner so she's walking
her [__] dog and I see her so Ashley
what's the story ten minutes before you
okay I was outside getting some sun and
she goes the biopsy didn't come back yet
but I think it's fungal
I think that you have like a fungal
that's in my body because I have the
fungi toenails better than uh cancer we
can't take the [__] uh the pills for
it because it destroys your liver oh boy
so if you have the you have the toenail
too it's between my pinky and my my next
toe and it's the same cream you're using
yeah you put it on your feet your
clothes I put [__] yeah at night it's
got to be exposed I gotta wear slippers
right and my wife hates my feet she did
it because my wife don't like them
either it's disgusting I got a bunion
that hasn't hurt in 30 years
so and my one toe I took the nail out
this is years ago
the big toe and my mother-in-law says it
looks like the head of a poop which is
octopus
Boop is how you say
well we're bodies that's a whole
different dialect okay there's nobody
Don Sicilian gallebrae's Bari is on the
other side of the boot it's above the
heel okay and you got to say
we say pulpo yeah it's it's yeah mares
is like Chinese to Sicilians okay good
to know good to [__] yeah but yeah
been a long time man when I got here we
met at the Manila Pan Diner yes there
was eight people in there and it was
petrified that day that was the during
coven that was like oh my God think of
it I would just I remember getting every
time I was in the line I thought I was
gonna get covered with the window open
that's how bad it got into my [__]
mind like it just [__] me up so well
that [__] is slowly behind us oh my God
once you get coveted you're like okay
did you get the booster yeah me too I
got the booster the second booster
the booster that took me to outer space
I didn't get the second booster and I'm
not getting this booster no I'm done
with boosters I said you want to boost
it up right right one more boosted up
you know you go to [__] CBS they got
19 boosters
they want you to come in do the flu one
while you're here that Minute Clinic
yeah while you're here do the covert and
you should do the [__] shingles and
then while you're here do the eyelash
covet do the [__] you know what you
might as well give me your ass and I'll
shoot the monkey pox in there in case
you want to go to a gay bar for a
cocktail did you ever get tested for
covert yes they give it as footlong cute
tip I used to tell you where's that
going so I'm going to swab your nose I'm
like you're gonna give me a [__]
lobotomy with that but the picture of my
ass the beginning is a covered World a
[__] nightmare yes
there were lines for Wegmans you had to
wash your hands you before you went in
that was sick oh we didn't know I hate
when people get mad at us for how we
acted the beginning of the [__]
pandemic
people were dying we panicked right
which is normal guys we panicked and we
didn't know if I told you that Russia
just released a gas
that you're going to die between now and
a week from now until the gas gets here
you're gonna [__] Panic right once
it's New York you're going to see what
happens in New York if you're in Montana
you know what happened in New York 300
people are dead you're gonna [__]
Panic it was crazy realize what the
[__] going on oh put iodine in your
nose whatever they think yeah iodine
right they tell you something because
there's Russian people here yeah and
they told me the Russian mom told me buy
iodine and put in your eyeballs or
whatever all my shelves were canceled I
was going to bed after Jeopardy it was
horrible the quarantine
I'm still surprised I'm still married
you know I'm gonna tell you something 40
years with someone and you got a
question you know what you told me one
morning stop doing that like doing what
breathing
one morning my blinking was bothering
her
yeah it was it was it was it was a rough
period for a lot of people
um
people didn't know that's one of the
first things I read like three weeks
into it like maybe two or three weeks
into it I read that by people being
stuck in the house there's going to be a
lot of domestic violence yes yes so the
first time depression and anxiety
suicide was I went out to the couch and
I decided
I'm gonna make her an ally during all
this
I can't go to war with her every day
can't go to war about stupid things make
her an ally help her out right I was
working I remember working out outside
by myself and my bodies would have
tingled from the fear
like as I was working out my body would
get red and I go I gotta stop doing
something's not right you know so you
look at the beginnings of what happened
to us as a country and as Comedians and
as artists and as human beings look what
they're saying now kids are [__] up oh
yeah those kids those two years in the
house some kids are [__] up Joey the
world we grew up with is no more we come
from a different time
you know this is how they live today
with these cell phones that's it you
know if it's not an app they don't know
how to deal with it
we come from the streets they will never
wear the last link to the greatest
Generations in our family
my mother-in-law passed away in December
so now it's just me and my wife my kids
they don't you know it's
it's it's the world has changed it's
[__] upside down it's there's no more
morals values and people are [__]
crazy out there that's why I love what I
do you know make people laugh I saw the
other day somebody put something up on
Instagram that they worked hard on
how many just put it up you know
put a [__] star whatever be a heart
you know you do 10 hearts a day it's
good for your psyche you're being a nice
[__] person
but I I looked at the comment to see
what it was that she had drawn or
whatever I don't even know this person I
don't even know I don't even know how it
came into my field it would feed it was
such an interesting picture I read the
comments and like four comments for
people like me that were like that's
beautiful work you know
eight of them were like it sucks
I don't even know you
I don't even why would you say that the
social media
has been a double-edged sword for me
look without the social media I wouldn't
have the following I have me neither now
it's made into a [__] [__] show like
you just said you could put I'm gonna
adopt a kitten what's the matter with
dogs you don't like dogs I was molested
by a kitten I'm gonna block you holy
[__] it so you can't say nothing you
can't
you know what it is these mutants have
always been out there but the social
media just exposed it because now every
loser who lives under a [__] rock now
they have a voice
the delusional miserable jealous
narcissistic [__] scumbags
they would they couldn't do they
couldn't do what we did in a [__] in
a [__] week what we did in a day you
know how it baffles me that
he started paying attention to this
about 10 years ago and you're watching
these Sports when I go to the gym down
the corner right they have a TV in there
so when I'm on the bike I naturally it's
right there it's right [__] there so
I'm watching and I watch the sports
things you know I don't care about what
the skipping Shannon or whatever the
[__] but they sit there and like the
white dude I don't know who that is Skip
whatever what channel I don't [__]
know Fox Sports oh okay I don't have no
half of these people I understand uh
the other guy criticizing football
players but I don't understand a guy
that's never played football
criticizing [__] it bother I understand
sport Traders and all that stuff and
this is why like before I I don't talk
about a lot of [__] like people Hey Joe
talk about this current event I don't
know about it and I don't want to talk
about it unless I [__] know ins and
outs about it you know and it's like
what happened with
the covert thing like since we're
talking about this is really interesting
I thought about this [__] the other day
I forgot what I was in the [__] time
to look my mind that's why you don't
smoke dope in the morning you know what
I'm saying dope in the morning yeah
speaking of dope I I did a gummy before
I came here I feel very relaxed nice how
many milligrams just I think 250. so you
do you do just the gummies
I used to smoke pot I gag now gummies
are so convenient you know they just
sneak up on you it doesn't smell it's
nice I bought them from the voters I put
[__] mozzarella and [__] roast
beef and and gummies at livoti's they
had gummies yes they wanted enough
Freehold okay the one in Freehold but
THC gummies yeah oh they're in a glass
case oh [__] I have some more in the car
if you want no I got [__] gummies of
all Dimensions here we got all
dimensions of [__] gum but you gotta
do it and like you can't do it when you
shower I stayed at the shower head one
night for 45 minutes I didn't even turn
the water on I'm just staring at the
[__] thing
foreign
but my daughter she made a bong and of
an apple well no your daughter's too
young one day you're gonna get high with
her that's a beautiful bonding man I
don't want to do that no it'll you'll
see I don't want to do that my daughter
was a pastry with a pastry chef
a pastry chef for three [__] days she
got the attention span of a flesh Cube
my daughter
so she made a bong out of an apple I
come home I smoked the weed from the
front of the house she got this apple in
front of her face big plume of smoke
like Victoria what the [__] are you
doing but the neighbors all right Dad
you caught me I'm smoking weed didn't
you smoke weed Micah's mommy's still
sleeping how do you do it show me how it
works you cover this up
[__] when you inhale you taste the Apple
there's no burning but I got the
munchies I ate the [__] apple and now
you got double shot she's still pissed
off at me and I ain't her [__] bong
let me ask you this when was the last
time you smoked oh
a year ago really I gag I choke I it
happened listen I can't smoke a lot
anymore I could smoke three four bongs
and then I eat then I eat like I got
three [__] [__] you know see I
don't eat on reefer I'm past that point
really does it make you hungry no but
Edibles do you go to sleep weed keeps me
up coffee I could drink and go right to
sleep me too yeah
me too but we or indica
Indica will keep you up
sativa will keep the three different
types of weeds sativa Indica hybrid okay
and uh it's the one gives you more
energy nice but I'm an Indica guy I want
to see the devil I want to know
nah I like to drool I fall asleep I like
the I like all that I like to float in
my pools
my hot tub barbecue smoking pot and
lifting weights oh I never did that I
love all that [__] I'm gonna try that
that's good does it make you stronger
nah but it makes you forget about what
you're doing so
we'd like I did 2 000 push-ups nice did
you lift weights yeah the two thousand
because you keep forgetting I do 20
pushing so I do 20 push-ups then I do
ten push-ups beautiful I got a trainer
that'll blow her mind you had an
interesting career like myself we both
got a little recognition as we got older
yes do you think that was better
absolutely if I would have got it sooner
I think I would have been in a [__]
gutter somewhere me too you know in the
70s late 70s when I grew up in Brooklyn
I was you know doing crazy [__] you know
I I [__] I just I did Coke once it
gave me diarrhea I had [__] I was
spitting up I'm just a beer and pot guy
you know you know we I did some knocking
around and [__] and you know when you
grow up in Brooklyn in the late 70s you
know you've been around you've been
around the Wise Guys you know remember
angels with dirty faces Pat O'Brien and
James Cagney yes he was he he ran fast
that's why he he didn't get caught like
Rocky Sullivan did you know I got
friends that are either dead or in jail
so I I took you know
I was the class clown I started a Pips
comedy club with a Mobsters met the
lobsters Pips [__] that was the
[__] oldest Lenny Bruce performed
there I went on stage I used to the the
lineup was me Richard Jenny John
mulrooney
Otto and George I mean that was the
comedy boot camp that was the only Club
in a country where the [__] owner
would Heckle you Ray Garvey
God Rest his son
now he Ray Garvey owned in all those
years no it was three owners he was the
third on it used to be Seth and Marty
Schultz I never met them George Schultz
was they say where Rodney got I get no
respect from they say he got that line
from George Schultz oh Pips was the
[__] nucleus of Comedy back in the oh
yeah Woody Allen Joan Rivers
and now it's a [__] Russian
restaurant you know it's
I'm glad I started there
the first night I went on stage Andrew
Dice Clay was the MC that's how [__]
long I'm doing this dice didn't have
that character right away no he used to
be an impressionist he did Robert De
Niro uh Stallone and Travolta Travolta
and uh uh American uh [__] Eric
Roberts at a campfire
[__] hilarious
later on he got the whole dice persona
crazy how many people came out of Pips I
met Ray at the end where'd you start
excuse me where did you start Denver
really
wow
grew up here and never went to a comedy
club
my friends went couple times I went to
see Eddie Murphy I never you know I was
a cokehead I can't sit there and giggle
for [__] two hours
maybe uh mescaline yeah yeah but I just
didn't I wasn't into it I didn't know
and that I kicked myself in the ass for
it because you have all this training
here in New York that's available to you
and I was like
I didn't even know it existed I thought
that to be I thought to get in the movie
you had a bartend and somebody came in
and noticed you right and you got the
job like Bruce Willis you know that was
the story and Paul Rice you heard all
those stories oh yeah so we didn't know
where to start I didn't know that you
could go to an acting class and rehearse
and do all that [__] I went out to
Denver
did everything in the world that I could
tried everything I was a brick mason I
was an electrician I built walls I
[__] roofed I did everything and I
knew
I just kept calmly was in the back
burner it was always in the back burner
I'm like I'm never gonna I'm a felon
these people are nice white people you
know they do comedy they go home they
giggle right you know I didn't know the
underworld of comedy at the time that
there was so many drugs involved and I
knew the Belushi stories and I loved
Richard Pryor and then I just took a
stand-up comedy class when I got out of
prison shipping me calling no no yes I
did I met him watch my idol had all his
albums I met him in Washington genius he
was more than a comic he was like a god
Professor you know a tremendous
tremendous [__] writer man and he
really just
I respected him but I liked Pryor a
little more because he was on the Wild
Side absolutely more with the Coke and
the hookers the one with the red outfit
when he talks about the mafia oh my God
oh my God holy [__] come here
you gotta see it it's [__] great I
started with Pryor like in 73. I went to
my friend's house and his brother was a
junkie and we went over to listen to The
Beatles White Album and his brother came
out and said what the [__] you
[__] listening to and he put on
Richard Pryor is It Something I Said and
when I heard
uh Dracula versus the wino I was done I
was [__] done and then when I got out
of the prison I read that book by Lenny
Bruce about when he lived in the Chelsea
and all that [__] yep and I'm like what
else do what else do is a guy like me
want to do this is the perfect life he
works on a strip club in the burlesque
show he goes back to the Chelsea and he
shoots heroin at least he knows who he
is and I was content with being that
person as bad as it sounds I was content
that's the life of a stand-up comic we
were talking about this earlier this is
why it conflicts with guys like you and
I
I had a friend of mine talked to me last
week about his girlfriend and she's
getting some eating comedy and she wants
to headline that four years and I'm like
it's a [__] mistake four years like
it's a mistake I go you could headline
like a d room to get time but you're not
gonna put yourself in a good position he
goes why not and I go because
you have to develop a [__] muscle
there's a certain muscle and you at four
years you don't have I don't give a [__]
what you tell stage time I don't give a
[__] what you tell me in four years you
don't have that muscle you've got the
time
everybody's got the time I can go up
there and do three hours is it gonna be
funny not really is it going to be
entertaining I don't know but you know
these people don't care they want it all
too quickly she's younger and I'm like
that's insulting you know when there's
so many egos are bigger than their acts
well because they get a little bit of
heat and this is where
I had the heart like I would have never
had a career if it wasn't for social
media
I I did not like it my when Rogan would
say [__] to me about Twitter I'd go let
me ask you a question do you think that
Richard Pryor leaves The Comedy Store at
two o'clock and goes home to tweet
people right are you [__] [__]
that is not the path that we followed
could you imagine George Colin on
Facebook people would have seizures
seizures they'd be jumping off the ledge
but it's it's it's it's it's very
it's very uh like it wasn't who we were
right and I was telling Jimmy Florentine
two days ago I go I'll tell you when I
[__] knew social media I had to do
something when I saw Rogan sell out this
is like 2000 he sold out Irvine without
radio
was this after Fear Factor this is right
on the cusp of Fear Factor okay but
there was no advertising is what my
point was and he added two shows Fourth
of July weekend wow so yeah
so
uh
he [__] I walked in there and the
show was completely
sold out and I go how did you do this
without radio and he goes social media
that's the button and before that stuff
went down with Mencia and stuff right he
was packing The Comedy Store on Friday
nights packing it with social media so
I I figured you had to get on you know
once what's his name [__] blew up
then you everybody went through the
comedian the guy that jumped up and down
he's got a new special out Dane Cook oh
okay because Dame Dame was the
professional on MySpace and he uh
funny you mentioned Joe Rogan the last
time I saw him he this is like you ever
have one of those obscure
random memories yeah meanwhile you don't
know what the [__] you had for breakfast
it was the Boston comedy club and what's
West 4th Street Ministry yeah me and
Rogan he's Rob Schneider's on stage and
he used to have this bit about different
ways to use the word um dude dude dude
dude you know different situations he's
killing he's crushing me and Rogan are
up in the hallway he's about to go on
Rod got the light he's eating [__]
Chinese spare rib like Joe you're going
on soon yeah I know and he finished it
and then he got introduced that's it
that's that's my Joe Rogan story I'll
never forget the first time I worked
with your Rascals
West Orange West Orange that was one of
the greatest Comedy Club Danny McKenna
the only manager who could fought at
will if you say Danny do me for the fun
he could fight I can't do that I still
talk to him I'm do that I love him to
that the hairdo yeah I do hair dude the
hair dude didn't move but I think I
worked with you because I had a bad
experience with Rocky Laporte oh from
Chicago because he was mad because I was
improvising and they know he's too dirty
he's improvising he's this he's that
don't you love Comics so I go had to you
got to put me with a [__] Savage is
not going to complain about me because I
got the guy and the next time you come
it was you and that night you did a bit
about going on vacation with your kids
in a station wagon from Staten Island
you did 20 minutes and you're like and
the best part of it all that happened we
didn't even leave the [__] parking
spot yet and I [__] died and I called
Rogue and I go dog I'm working Rascals
with this [__] dude
Vinnie Vicki but that he's like oh my
God that dude's a [__] dangerous dude
be careful and you will [__]
destroyed I mean that I was in awe like
talking about the kids and getting the
station wagon and your wife was yelling
and and then I at one point you're going
all this and we didn't even get out of
the [__] Parkway yet
we didn't even get out of the parking
lot wow [__] dying what year was that
90 no
started in 91 I didn't work Rascals till
late 90s Camacho that had to be ninth
Tony Camacho only Camacho the big you
ever see his tongue thing
it's tremendous
I know you're probably thinking how the
[__] did I see yourself no that's not
good he's got a big tongue he'll display
it to people he's I haven't heard from
him or don't know where he's like the
best of [__] comedy right yeah he is
you know what I'm saying nobody else
right there I've seen her and all of
them yep and nobody he called me once
for a ride from the airport
hey you busy today can you give me a
ride to the airport I'm like are you
[__] crazy Tony Camacho this is the
sweetest guy though nice guy he calls me
up once it's uh Vic uh what are you
doing May 1st and 2nd it's a Tony I'm
booked with you
I was booked he didn't know he had me
put the sweetheart of a guy
pick his tongue if you think of all
those people that we came across oh my
God and I call these people ain't I'm
thinking of writing another book and I'm
calling it Angels just to give these
people credit of people that came into
your life yeah on the [__] road like
people had no reason to talk to you at
the time because you know we weren't
nobody knew who the [__] we were right
and these people went out of there wait
for you they took you to eat they showed
you I missed that whole lifestyle I
[__] missed that that small mind the
comedy tournamental right once it gets
too big you enjoy it yes and you look
around and you go this is what I worked
for all those years I'm very happy I
attained it but then you realize what
you really want to do and what works for
you right you'll come take it away well
you should do [__] uh amphitheaters
guess what man I love the money I'll
make on Amphitheater but you know what I
love more the personal and the I like
smaller rooms like Uncle Vinnie's that's
perfect for Uncle Finney he's also been
a great
the bohem and Jerry Dino has been and
Jerry's a sweetheart I I talk more with
Dino but Jerry's a great guy he's always
there
but Dino has been uh a [__] godsend
did he ever tell you that story I'm on
stage and they they literally you know
when you're on stage and to the left two
people sit there it was two guys one guy
was was like this he was about to fall
asleep the other guy was like this
and he was looked like he was about to
throw up Dino and Jerry just pulled the
chair with the guy on it out it was like
a scene from Goodfellas out the back
door
pushed the chair into the [__] all
that garbage juices
and they're kicking him and beating the
[__] out of him and they closed the door
his partner has still no idea that what
the [__] just happened there I was on
stage while this happened and I'm doing
my act you know just to keep the
audience attention away but next time
you talk to dino
that's my Uncle Vinnie's story I think
that was a little better than my Joe
Rogan story yeah but I love Dino I love
going down there uh
it's a small yeah [__] place and it
really like you want to go into the city
some nights you want to go to Caroline
you want to do this and you're like you
know what I'm just gonna go to the point
I love Dina but we gotta have a talk to
him he's got to make a [__] Green
Room he's got to clean out that office
and that little green room for the
comics what do you think
right next to the bathroom I don't care
whatever the [__] he does in there at
this point it's such a cute little class
I mean agreement where do you hang out
when you go to the Green Room that's not
a green room it's his office but it is
what it is that's why I hang he probably
cleans it up for you no it's fine when I
get there there's [__] boxes on the
couch I still got a blanket that
somebody gave me for a show every night
I go Dina I got to bring this home okay
I'll give it to you and every night I
come home and I'm like [__] I forgot
that blanket you know we're getting old
we like that little boy yeah oh yeah
this is your [__] stinky feet at
night oh yeah my balls are touching the
toilet water now yeah oh please when I
pee my boys will touch my balls were
touching them when I was [__] 45 who
the [__] are you kidding but this social
like listen the when I got into comedy I
struggled for a long time like you did
right
what
were you praying for to happen I'm just
curious what like for me to break it
down for you for me
I sustained comedy as hard as I'm uh as
much as long as I could
but I was waiting for the day I could
tell my story
I always knew in the back of my head
because I was watching HBO once you hate
a boxer right you might hate a boxer but
when you watch that [__] the up you
know they're fighting enthusiasts and
they take you to their house
you meet their wife and also you're like
that [__] that animal's got six kids
he puts nail polish on with his daughter
that [__] and you're like oh I like
this guy now you know it's not them just
seeing you with a microphone and talking
about you know what you're what's on
your mind but I always knew what was
your thing and I didn't know was the
internet was going to provide it for me
I didn't want to drive a school bus the
rest of my life
you know because I'd be coming in and
I'd see guys my age and all the you know
playing cards I said I don't wanna I'm
it was scary I didn't know
2013 was the perfect storm in my career
I signed with a great manager who who
tripled my money and got me off the
school bus Kevin James calls me out of
nowhere puts me in Mall Cop too I get a
viral video called bread of milk
and the fans
I I was selling tickets it was beautiful
you know I just didn't want to have a
regular job the rest of my life I always
wanted to be a comedian you know there's
different levels of success she got the
Sebastian maniscalco's the Dave
Chappelle's the bill Burrs the Joe
Rogan's
I'm happy where I am I'm not in the
stratosphere
but I'm selling out theaters and clubs
I'm on tour with this young kid Eric de
la sanjo who's also got a huge social
media platform I'm in a TV show that's
going to be an Amazon Prime called
Gravesend
I'm healthy I got a beautiful wife still
turns me on we had [__] amazing sex
last night it was [__] beautiful it's
[__] she takes she buys outfits I
hear all these guys like when you spoke
about being married in your last podcast
either work it out or you get divorced
if you meet the right person the woman
in this business that's half the battle
that's half the battle you know
that's what happened with me I met a
woman and uh she swept me
and we're grounded we're grounded guys
like us are like caribou and the herd is
thinning
it's interesting the way you just put
that but not not I don't mean about
dying in a 20 30 years
we come from a Different Cloth no no you
don't think I know that when I talk to
people I I felt out of place all my life
sometimes you know especially when I
went out west I always felt like out of
place you know
and then my daughter tells me all the
time she's like Dad you're from a planet
that doesn't exist anymore you know our
thoughts do not people don't want to
know our thoughts you know it's like
interviewing Pete Rose is not good for
your health right you don't know what
that [__] is going to put in the
Hall of Fame already you know all these
guys you know with us listen to
Stranglehold oh my God how great is that
is that a great song walk up to the
stage too oh please and the audience
goes [__] bananas but you look at all
the variables to Comedy and stuff and
I'm very
happy right now I mean I'm happy I got
the opportunity to run with those guys
I'm happy I got to The Comedy Store and
I got accepted in there and stuff but
that was then and this is now and this
is now and now it's a different chapter
in our lives and you have to look at it
differently I look at these guys having
a great time and I don't I'm not jealous
I don't I feel bad right it's not like I
should be doing that I'm gonna get on
the phone and I I'm doing exactly what I
want to be doing right now I'm older I
don't see the whether listen after
[__] our boy died in a hotel room
that made me think who's that
the guy from that [__] show the
really good guy Bob Saget he's a really
good guy yeah and listen guys we all
gonna [__] die yep you're all gonna
die I want you to pick your [__] way
or how you're gonna dive until I was 45
I thought I was gonna get shot you know
I thought I was gonna get shot or OD or
whatever my fear I don't want to die in
a hotel room on the road [__] that [__]
you you know ah [__] you after I read
that guys and I know it's happened
before Comics have passed there's a guy
who had the sitcom had all the the
success who [__] at 63 to be in
Orlando in a [__] Comedy Room no no
you love comedy so do I that's why
there's The Comedy Store right go there
every [__] night if that doesn't
satisfy your whistle go to the
improviser that doesn't satisfy your
whistle then go to Laugh Factory you
know you have so many opportunities if I
want to do comedy I could go to Uncle
Vinnie's I can go to the stress Factory
I go to tips I go the [__] nine clubs
here oh I go in the [__] City and
that's what people have not understood
that right right you know it's it was
great it was a great time in my life but
right now I like I was telling you I'd
rather go to a softball game and hang
out with the parents I just got a call
from one of the parents can you drop off
some weed at this so you know this is
what life is all about it's like and
it's great that worked then yes you know
when I did that kidnapping I was doing a
couple of those kidnappings that worked
then I didn't have nobody at home that
worked then but it wouldn't work now
right I couldn't leave this morning and
go honey I'm going to kidnap that dude
I'm going to do a drug rip I'll be back
with 50 000 at lunchtime you're [__]
nuts I wouldn't even know how to carry a
gun anymore and shoot I don't know how
to do that tie somebody up with a rope I
forgot all that [__] already that's not
my life anymore so comedy is my listen
when your comedians like being a house
Angel right it's like being a musician
you know I didn't make it to the Marines
I didn't make it to a lot of things but
I made it to be a regular at the store
and I got in with a group of guys that
mentored me and I mentored them we all
got a chance to help each other and this
is what this comedy game is and I see
what you're doing and I'm like [__]
Vic's killing it with the videos and the
but you didn't know what it was and one
day you made a video right and you
looked at it an hour later I had a
million hits yeah you're like holy [__]
and
I work hard at it me and my manager I
got a great relationship he's more of a
friend than a manager but he helps me
with the videos I got to come up with
different content you know how hard that
is every day since 2009 oh I do
characters I do this over the top
character Tony Gaga you got a guy it's
stupid that's a i imitate the Giants
coach the Yankees coach after the games
I do a post game locker room I do ticked
off Vicks my mother-in-law used to cook
with me it's it's hard man but I'm I'm
working hard and nobody's helping me and
my manager we're just doing it all on
our own and then when you do somebody's
Club they expect you to promote well
[__] help me out you know because
like like I Bronx Tale going back nobody
cares nobody okay right but they don't
care and on the hind side of that not
the insulture or anything like that
I think that a lot of comics relied on
that for years and in today's model
like today these Comics that are coming
up now right they're gonna have to do
that they're gonna have to I did it
because I didn't want to walk into a
room empty room right they don't know
but you got to be a comedian first you
have to be a comedian because if they do
the video I go on stage let me see you
kill in 20 1200 people for an hour what
are you gonna do for an hour that you
did in the videos
you know they don't you got to be a
comedian first
well that's the problem we have that's
the problem that I have I don't have a
problem with this like I told a friend
of mine the other day I live in the
[__] 70s I still live by the Pennzoil
commercial pencil you could pay me now
or you could pay me later right you want
to shoot a video get 2 million hits
say you're a comedian and then you get
brought up on that stage you're going to
get a world of hate I don't uh you're
gonna be brought into a world that
you're not going to be familiar with if
you want me to tell you my opinion on
what's going on with that type of stuff
it's not going to be good and
but
what I'm trying to [__] put together
is that
it's not the natural way to become a
comedian oh absolutely not but this will
listen when you get a million views and
then you you your manager goes hey man
Comics are doing this you should just go
up there and talk just listen I've heard
the speech
that agents give their actors agents the
Bottom Feeders yeah and they'll say like
hey Mike you were a singer in a band why
don't you just tell jokes for 45 minutes
and you're like but I'm not a comedian
who cares
just go up there and talk 45 minutes
here like that's [__] disrespectful
to people like me and him and right and
[__] you know Jerry whatever and
[__] Jimmy and Richmond you're
disrespecting the art that we created
here that we've created for ourselves
right writing by by so you just want to
do it differently you you and I both
know that the train ends badly oh yeah
that train ends badly because you got to
emcee you got a feature and you really
got to learn how to emcee to control a
[__] show and that'll catapult you up
the [__] headlining when you're ready
anybody who overdoes that you got to pay
your dues you're gonna pay your dues you
can take that money I I dog I would take
it too when I was stupid right when
you're stupid and you're you're broke
you'll take that money and you'll do
things you're not supposed to one rule I
learned off the bat don't go nowhere you
don't belong
don't go nowhere where you don't belong
if I see you in a club then you come up
to me as an agent go I am Vic I'm really
funny what time's your set I'm not here
at the new comedy I'm here to support
Jimmy Floren thing you know what go [__]
yourself I want you know don't there's
just so many things that have gotten out
of control but in the long run when you
see the YouTubers and a lot of these
guys I wish him a lot of success I
really do well they found their Niche
good for them that their success is not
gonna be
would stand up unless they go back to
the Grind exactly I saw an interview
with some young up and coming uh YouTube
guy had to be like a year ago somebody
sent me this thing because of that
because of that conversation this kid's
saying I'm gonna do comedy differently
or whatever listen comedies comedy music
is music funny is funny funny is funny
you're not gonna change that [__]
place whether you're clean dirty black
or white
impersonated [__] Gallagher Seinfeld
funniest funny except for Yoko Ono she
couldn't make anything
that was just [__] bad yo go on oh
you're going on it's just [__] bad
but it just seems that hard work has
always been the key for me absolutely
yeah you're gonna [__] skate at times
listen I've skated a ton of times I'm
skating right now you know what I'm
saying but
that [__] you're gonna have to go back
and do the work I'm sorry I love these
things on Instagram you know your
podcast is worth a million dollars a
month it's fine with us and we'll teach
you they're having a clue they don't
have a [__] clue you got to be on
stage you gotta got a bomb bombing
humbles you bombing makes you better you
know I love these guys they come off
stage oh I [__] kills meanwhile all
you heard were crickets yeah you never
kept anybody who comes off Facebook
delusional [__] it's it's sad it's
wow and thank God you guess see that's
that's what the other thing you get is
you get experience
you're gonna experience how to deal with
people how to deal with different crowds
how to deal with I was like the show one
time beautiful girl kept coming up every
week in Seattle every week every week
every week 10 weeks she was there guys
were offering her gigs I'm sitting back
there giggling my [__] because this
chick wasn't any good and they put her
on the show one night and I was part of
that show she went up there trying to be
a feature act she was up there four
minutes and some guy goes show me your
[__] just
show me your [__] like that this girl
[__] dog I saw it she just lost
Consciousness she put the mic in and she
walked off wow and I never saw an open
mic again holy [__] how do you follow
that no it's not even the following the
thing I'm mentioning is how she thought
she was ready to be a feature act after
10 [__] right of course and I sat
there and watched it you know how many
times I sat at the bro well now that's
at The Comedy Store with one of these
Montreal comics
oh just for laughs yeah he was doing
comedy like six years and went up to
Montreal and got like a million dollars
and they decide to bring this
[__] to the store like the
agents didn't know what they were doing
oh boy he walked in with nine Jews you
know those Comics oh yeah when they come
back from Montreal awesome those agents
are following they're tapping you they
like your cigarettes they're rubbing
your shoulders you gotta see it oh I had
a friend that got a half million dollar
deal I knew when the deal didn't go
through because he wasn't with him every
time I saw that guy for two years he was
with my buddy and also I saw him one
night I go where's your buddy oh he had
someone to go two days later the deal
fell through a fox like well hit that a
[__] please I saw a guy that was good
looking you know one of those good
looking young Comics that they fall in
love with Hollywood oh he's oh my God we
love him guys never made a [__]
nobody laugh maybe his sister and his
mom
he [__] walked in with eight Jews and
the Jews didn't check to see it was on
the lineup
and Mitzi put this YouTube Star behind
Andrew
Doug you should have seen the panic in
his face Andrew's face no the kid oh
okay you gotta follow Andrew oh boy from
Montreal you know they're lighting his
cigarettes rubbing how did it go how did
it go how the [__] do you think it went
[Laughter]
and until you see that
you see that a million times let me tell
you something and you feel it because I
saw the life sucked right out of him
right out of him I saw another kid that
this kid just was a great Wordsmith
but they were they were headlining him
after a year at one of the one of the
top clubs talk and people were like come
on and he kept sticking to him and this
guy paid Gersh he brought him to
Hollywood and did a complete showcase
him
but where they stopped persons the
comedy start on a Sunday night and I
watched it I watched him come in there
yeah we got the and I went up the Mitch
and I go missing I'm gonna bring this
guy up
by the way he's the next Bill Hicks and
she looked at me she goes really okay
this kid went up in the original room on
a Sunday dog he went up there he had
every all the Hulk comic outfit you know
the skull cap the whole you know
three minutes and Mitzi was yelling from
the back get him off the stage Bill
Hicks my ass
see you soreled that I never went to the
West Coast I never went to L.A but you
saw it here yeah what I'm saying what I
saw on the west coast you saw here right
many a night at Caroline's when some guy
walking I just got a big and they got on
stage and they got to follow some
[__] guy that doesn't know the
meaning he didn't get the memo they're
the Leonard Skynyrd's of the 70s they
never got the memory when they opened up
for the stones you know you're opening
up for the stones you got to do this and
this and this and this but it's like we
didn't get them did he come off stage
and say I killed no this kid [__]
came off stage and here's the saddest
part the people who brought him up
weren't even walking with him anymore he
was walking 20 feet ahead of him and
they were walking behind him because
what a business because this is the
business we chose and I see those
situations and I think of all these
people that go somewhere before the time
see you have bro you're a [__] you're
the king because
you and me put the work in I never had a
look over my shoulder I never had to
worry about it when I go on some
upbringings for how you brought up you
know I was I was taught a hard work
ethic I used to drive when I had the
school bus my route was in Staten Island
so
I lived here in Jersey I'd get up 4 30
in the morning go over the Outer Bridge
go to Staten Island do my run
and between runs you got like a few
hours till you picked the kids up from
school I would come back to Staten
Island and do this like the Outer Bridge
four times a day during the week when I
was booked at the Borgata
when Ray Garvey first put the book on a
comedy club in Atlantic City at the
polgata I'd be booked there for seven
nights I would be going back after my
show go back home sleep four hours get
up drive the [__] school bus in
Staten for five [__] nights in a row
you think these [__] guys
you gotta break your balls man you gotta
you just can't be giving it to you you
got to work for it
you know it tastes a lot better and you
can't learn this [__] you can't go to a
[__] comedy School
come on
this is like prison time it's time
served [__]
it's time served this is times listen I
remember I did an episode of Myron
Marin uh he wrote an episode for Arnie
and already told me he didn't want to do
it after he wrote it Hardy Lang yeah I
don't want to do it I don't want to fly
out that way so you know I did it and I
never forget that day like I hadn't
acted in a while like it had been like a
window like a year by the way you were
great in uh many Saints to do it until I
got shot I know I don't want to say it
in case anybody who didn't see the movie
yeah that's [__] scared the [__] you
didn't [__] dude after a year no how
do they do that like it was CGI
it's not like the [__] head explodes
okay got it nothing that was great
nothing you feel when you saw your
funeral scene that that like [__]
freak you out but they show you a
picture and they had to come and tell me
the picture was for the funeral I was
like Wow
but uh you know I went on that set first
time I saw you was Spiderman Spiderman
you got to go through me first that's
right that was [__] great that was
[__] crazy man but it's weird how you
hobbyist
I grew up watching movies I copy what
they do when I go to an audition if
that's if you want to know the truth you
know you look at these scenes and you
know how I booked that soprano movie I
remembered an episode
where they did and they were having a
conversation Sylvia and Tony Soprano
Bruce Springsteen was playing
and during the episode Tony looks at
Sylvia and he goes
and Sylvia nods his head so when I got
that audition they were telling me a lot
of people having a hard time with that
audition music comes on
and that was my line
my mom met his mom one time and that's
when uh God Rest his soul the guy from
tariko Henry Hill says well Leota yeah
Ray Liotta says uh whatever the [__] you
know we start talking about Sinatra
right but I did the thing I looked up
for us in the audition tape and I put
pointed up and I go my mother met his
mother one time it's not that I'm an
actor it's that I stole that when I saw
Tony and silver they loved that [__] and
they loved that [__] so that that that's
it but I when I got on the set for that
it was like two thousand you gotta write
a book it's coming up April 23rd of next
year Beautiful Brown you could order it
already on Amazon absolutely so uh when
I got that job that day well I was
shooting and I know this has happened to
you this happened to me a lot the last
right before the pandemic this has
happened to me a lot on stage when I was
doing theaters
when I got to that set of of uh Marin
that day you know I was everybody was
there all the agents were there right my
age and I had like BBA at the time that
didn't show up to those things you know
but all the other agents were there with
all their star comedic talents [__]
Bottom Feeders and I'm [__] laying it
down I'm [__] laying it down they're
like improvised do what you wanna man
and I'm looking at all these agents
faces with their little [__] [__]
comics and they're looking at me like
holy [__] this guy is killing it and I
remember that day going wow
can't believe that I'm this good I got
this good I shocked myself like I knew
where to stand where was this this is in
La I was shooting the Marin Mark married
and I'll never forget that I was then
going how the [__] did I get this good
at this you know I wasn't saying it to
anybody right because I was very
familiar what I was doing I was good at
it
I thought back to the longest yard
because I was on that set for 17 [__]
weeks and you can never replace that wow
17 weeks you just learned something
little certain things it's like going on
a tour with Guns and Roses you go on a
tour of Guns and Roses as an opening act
for a year you're gonna come back with a
couple [__] things absolutely when
the guy again we're going back to The
Sopranos you're not recording this right
and he goes just to let you know I've
recorded Luxembourg you know like those
[__] idiots so that's the problem the
powers that be are clueless you know
well they couldn't see Talent if it was
in front of them you know it's it's
a [__] up business
with auditions I spell it out for them
well I got a call for an audition I
don't put it right on tape I think about
it for a few days I'm more nervous in
the audition than in front of 3 000
people are you the same
like are you nervous in front of three
people reading the script no see I'm
nervous I got over it it took me a while
like I still remember reading for the
original Sopranos in 99. who'd you read
it with uh
producers I went to produce this three
times for three different characters
Gigi Sharif is character and then they
call me in to be a stand-up comic but I
wasn't available that week but I read
for them and I never forget reading for
Gigi and my sheets were still shaking
even though I know my lines I knew him
backwards and forwards right I always
bring my sides in to keep me uh centered
but I still remember them yeah but I
still remember going to auditions with
Travolta wow I'm knocking it out of the
park like not even knowing that Travolta
was there like I still remember going on
audition I'm coked up from last night I
get there at 10 o'clock on a Monday
and it's Billy Gardell and Me Oh Billy
goddell and I'm like okay good guy you
go Billy you read yeah all right I
[__] walk in there Travolta in the
room we gotta read with the Vault what
was this for what movie
it was for the Jimmy roselli story
did it ever happen that was my father's
favorite singer it never happened
he did the movie roselli Jimmy roselli
he got blackballed by Sinatra yeah and
they're not singing at his mother's yes
birthday party [__] great story oh
yeah Jimmy Roselle this was a great
[__] script wow he canceled it Leota
was gonna play uh Travolta was going to
play he's gonna play him and me and
Billy Gardell were going to be his
opening acts on the road
the [__] script I'll look and I'll
give it to you because I think I still
got it it's is it a dead issue and it's
that issue ah dad I love to revamp it
though bro was all set and Hoboken the
[__] it we were gonna be in Hoboken for
eight weeks we were gonna stay in this
city you have no [__] idea and he
picked that micro [__] that
Scientology movie with the Martians and
the thing he took that instead oh
something with Mars in the title yes
that was Jack Nicholson yeah no it was
just him I think he took that [__]
Battle Star [__] piece of [__] that
roselli ship was hysterical Doug the
father used to play Mala femina and he
was he was really good he had a great
voice oh my God and he used to sell out
Jimmy roselli he used to sell albums out
of his trunk because he was blackballed
and all the Italian Wise Guys would go
oh Jimmy come on you're embarrassing me
close the [__] trunk go around the
corner and sell those it was a great
script it was a great [__] script wow
yeah he got Blackboard because Jimmy Roy
he didn't sing at Sinatra's mother's
birthday party so you know could some
young comic on [__] YouTube know what
we're talking about
aren't you glad
well this is what I tell people the
experience that was Dean Martin
celebrity Rose and Red Skelton Johnny
Carson [__] up with B Martin get on
national TV on a Thursday night and we
would sit there I still remember Sanford
and Son and Chico and the Man on Friday
nights ordering a pizza alone Americans
would come over we'd swap spit and then
I'd dry hump on the debt for like 20
minutes until I was sweating and [__]
she said why ain't gonna stop dry
humping me later later dry humping wow
the fact the other day I saw something
that was tremendous somebody sent me a
[__] video of two dogs [__] and
then they got stuck did anybody else see
that then they go back to bed
did you see the video and it's like the
yelping and yeah oh yeah you know dogs
when I was a kid as soon as you pulled
up into the Bronx you see two dogs
[__] Jesus Christ and then the owner
chasing like a fat Italian grandmother
get away from my poodle she's [__] a
German shepherd with a big black dicks
[__] he's running backwards because
he's running forward and [__] you know
people forget all about that stuff you
know being a kid and playing buck buck
you know explain what but you know what
is that pillow oh okay Johnny on the
pony and we call the fire hydrant Johnny
pumped the Johnny pump but then if you
land you use the Johnny pump and
somebody jumped on you you Bang Your
Head where you [__] open the thing
and then you'd have that octagon and you
[__] head trust me I had a friend
that still has knocked the gun you had
to put like Charles Manson with the
[__] God he had that [__] octagon
right in this goddamn head
I don't think this has been uh
I feel like having cake and coffee with
you now you know no I got to see you a
lot more because we live down here six
minutes away that's it so maybe we'll do
something at [__] uh whatever you
want I'd love to do yeah let's do it
I'll surprise him one night you you know
do your Wednesday night and just okay I
can't do anything now because I'm doing
parks at your convenience no [__] I'm
I got a 120 feet radius right no rush
yeah something like pox is a great gig
you're gonna like that I love it it's
beautiful last time I did box I just
jumped off the stage into the audience I
didn't even go in the back room they
were so crazy great staff great Green
Room the great Green Room [__] hot
dog yeah I'm doing it the night before
Thanksgiving that's it who are you doing
it with Eleanor Kerrigan Eleanor nice I
think Florentino stop by you're old
beautiful come pick up an envelope
we'll take a bus down we'll [__] get
Chinese food wow why do you eat Chinese
food Empire
uh to go out for dinner picking Pavilion
on 33. now that's really good homemade
Chinese what made Chinese I heard Joe
listen to me the best Chinese spare ribs
Kings in Freehold on route nine really
by the Staples trust me the [__] meat
falls off the bone it's Tibet Kings how
good is the pork fried rice excellent
but for nice fancy would you take your
wife peeking Pavilion I heard the best I
like shrimp and lobster sauce with pork
in it with the little bits of pork and
the only people who do it around here is
the uh
oh not the P King the one on the if you
go opposite cousins and Astoria
I know what you mean the the that place
is good that place got a mean triple
Lobster but they're rude
they're rude they don't talk to us yeah
they don't [__] talk to you know the
guy came up I thought he was a [__]
he's like to take the dish unbelievable
the [__] Hoops I gave him the credit
card she's going I don't know she meant
tap tap okay I'm sticking it in I'm
sliding it now you go to your top a top
oh tap
it's hard you know to understand that
food down here is very good you know you
can't get good pizza and bagels in
Jersey [__] you yes you can where do you
get your bagels uh they bring them from
Staten Island for me okay no argument
there how do I beat that one yeah if I'm
around neighborhood I train at Old
Bridge so I go to Bagel Boy sometimes
you like Brooklyn Pizza yeah that for
the square oh yeah yes Brooklyn Square
in Brooklyn yes I like that place I like
uh I like the other [__] deninos oh
of course I like Carlos yep I like Carla
I like John a lot I call those he's a
good dude
and Lido's the queen de La Creme not
your typical Italian restaurant
I like El Nido I love [__] uh
I love uh Australia Angelo never been
there [__] great guy you know what I
get in there when I go simple
escrow and beans that's almost like
pasta fazool right the soup I get a bowl
this [__] bacon I told her bring me
some bread parmesan cheese and crushed
red pepper
I'm good I can't if I go to Cheeseburger
night on Monday nights you gotta go to
cheeseburger in that Astoria 16.95
cheeseburger a beer I want a nice
spaghetti carbonara with a glass of
merlot oh [__] fried kalamad that
appetizer then Patera masseuse dessert
with a cappuccino then you could put me
to the electric chair oh my God they got
Cafe Luna yeah it's right by me [__]
great they just guys we live in an area
that if you want Italian food
you're gonna get it and you could get it
they got that place across the Mine by
Wild Wings the town Coosa Casa whatever
in there they don't [__] around in there
you know I love it that my I got down
here because I had a brother who lives
in Morganville I used to come down here
in 2000 unbelievable
I would go to live a fish with him out
of the Fulton Fish Market crazy out of
all the places you're [__] six
minutes for me you [__] believe this
and this is I haven't seen you since
Rascals and and here we are no but I
bumped into you once after that I think
I bumped into an L.A one night
oh that had to be when I was out there
with okay with Joe Maroney I did Big B's
yes yes where is Pasadena yes the other
one Rosie O'Donnell used to book it what
was the name of that place the Ice House
the ice house yeah the Ice House comedy
so I just went in never went on stage I
was just an awe it was just wow The
Comedy Store you know people understand
like like go look up
for me being from Jersey the things I
saw what I went through it would have
just been an honor to walk in the
comedies absolutely to perform there for
a guy like me that's like an HBO special
right that's what these people will
never understand for everybody else it's
uh uh not that big of a deal but for me
to be a regular at the store that's like
me being in the U.S Marine Corps that
goes forever that you can't take that
away from anybody that there's a lot of
people who became regulars and were
there for like a year and they moved on
I was there for 20 [__] years wow I
was a regular active regular guy you
went from Denver to The Comedy Store no
I went from Denver to Seattle okay wow I
went from Denver and I came back here
how did they take you in Denver and
Seattle like this
rock this tough it's loud New Jersey
camera on them yeah the camera's still
on Vic yeah
um
you got to remember one thing
here I would have been a nuisance but in
Denver
do you remember when we were kids we had
the same four Italians on TV
the two morons from [__] uh the one
[__] from [__] uh Laverne and
Shirley oh wait The Big Ragu yeah
Fonzie you had Fonzie you had the big
Italian guy oh what was it Levine's
father yeah the guy that was on the
sitcom guy that I love Robert pastorelli
that was my [__] Idol I got to meet
him know the name which which show
he did one of those shows with Karen I
don't know but he was a typical Italian
whenever they won there was like four of
them and whenever you watch TV from the
70s now okay you'll see these four he's
one of those character actor Italians
yeah and then a couple years ago I did
children's hospital and I ended up
working with the guy from
Laverne and Shirley he just passed away
the big rat goal yes Eddie Mecca Eddie
Mecca he just passed away I did uh
whatever we got to talk and he was like
when I got into this there was like five
battalions Austin it's like they opened
they out opted the [__] boat out to
L.A you look more Italian than me please
I'm not even holy [__] in Cuban if even
if a Cuban guy writes it they'll never
they wrote that cue Al Pacino played
Scarface yeah but that's but I'm talking
about I'll never work on a Cuban movie
don't ever give me one of those because
I don't look Cuban enough
so like they called Andy Garcia who
knows me and said do you want him from
father to bride he's like that's the
last guy I want on my set wow but
everything I've ever booked is Italian
but back to your question you weren't
born in Cuba uh yeah yeah oh you were
yeah
I got smuggled into this [__]
1960. you're a political Refugee
political Refugee you know what I'm
saying but you think about this when I
started in Denver they helped me with
open arms and when I started in seat
when I went I went from Denver to New
York for nine months that's how I met
Mike boschetti Mike Bishop the New York
comedy club how whatever I met a couple
other people but they moved on we share
a lot of those I bet that's Dave
Chappelle at the boys club never met
Dave met him at the Boston Comedy Club
then in 93 then I went back to Colorado
I was serious about comedy did it there
for about two years then went to Seattle
and Seattle was a great comedy scene you
know they ranged this is during the uh
the Kurt Cobain days and they just died
94. I got the Seattle
June July of 95 and I stayed till 98 and
then I got a deal from CBS and I moved
to [__] L.A
and that was
and look at you now
and this I mean this is bad and this is
bad no this is not what's wrong with
this nothing your daughter's coming home
soon right I mean not four four o'clock
is uh no school today Jewish holiday
there you go so fresh on Homer there we
go to softball practice tonight and then
I don't know whatever the [__] happened
but I'm happy we're blessed we are
blessed yes we are man we're very
[__] lucky man thank you this is so
nice thank you around the corner anytime
you want to come in and talk about the
Jets the Giants the Yankees you know
you're always welcome all right and one
that will do something at uh over the
holidays let's do something yeah let's
do something in December and you got to
taste my wife's big ziti okay I wasn't
gonna say something else is it good Jeff
Joey it's trust me
some lady just gave me some baked ziti
yesterday you're gonna tell all these
neighbors to go [__] themselves after
you taste my wife was [__] good
really good I mean [__] really good I
like it without the meat but yeah I
would like to go to El Nido you and your
wife and my wife you let me know you
[__] let me know and I want to go to
the butcher box
where was that oh that's where oh dear
yeah that's in like New Brunswick
that's a great Steakhouse it's kind of
places Factory even cousins open there
cousins open there oh I love the stage
three floors and cousins now where he's
got three floors the new cousins in uh
New Brunswick yeah it's across from
Uncle Billy never been there yet I've
been you got to check it out the other
day I love cousins I love all those
these restaurants are great in New
Jersey people have no [__] idea what
they miss you know Red Bank has some
great absolutely raspberry have you got
that 518 yet 618 yeah in Freehold I
loved it better than El Nido
uh I'll take El Nido what do you get at
El Nido the uh the black squid oh [__]
no that's my favorite all right it's my
favorite thing right squid with the toe
crab yes crab top you know it's perfect
they give you the perfect portion you're
not out there like and I've heard people
get mad because they're like oh the
portions no it's it's worth it's worth
it it's [__] worth it I love the
black ink pasta I love the the I like
simple [__] yeah like I can't eat no
more stuffed shells
stuff gets me heavy on my stomach I love
Seafood oh I love seeds I just don't
like I don't like sushi to me that's
bait I like it you know my wife loves
Sushi I love rice you like oysters no I
don't know it's got to be cooked the
[__] have you had the seafood towel for
men later yes no no you mean cousins El
Nido they have one too
oh boy
okay I got a change of plans
play is good over there
and uh I want to sit well you can see
the cook in the the booth yeah space in
the kitchen yeah you know we'll have
some privacy oh it's great man it's
[__] great I love going and I miss
Joe
I missed my daughter Mrs Joe oh wow he
wanted to put me in like he owns that
home strip he wanted to do like a comedy
night that's what they want to do yeah
he told me he goes he wanted to move the
tile place and he was I was I wanted to
open up a coffee shop over there
because they just up opened up a coffee
shop on the other side of town it's not
that good the coffee was stale and it
wasn't [__] hot like I want my coffee
hot coffee's got to be hot it's got to
be piping hot we must have went to every
[__] Carriage machine because I
didn't like the temperature until one of
them says as it's setting he could set
it high it's got to be hot cool I like
hot coffee though man what's your next
date
uh this is embarrassing but I really
don't give a [__] because I feel very
comfortable with you I'm gonna read it
off a piece of paper so I don't forget
anything because I was so pumped to be
here to plug myself Hard Rock Casino
October 14th and 15th
Count Basie November 5th Uncle Vinnie's
November 26th
and that's that
November 26 is what I have no idea I
just wrote November 26th you more than
welcome to come and say hello and do a
guest spot I would be honored yeah
because I asked him one night I just
don't want to go down there I want to go
down there and watch them so you're
there November
26th yeah we could even eat it at a
restaurant there's a lot of you ever go
to the poached pair no I'll be there
just 20 seconds and the Prime Steak that
I would put that second to 6 18. Prime
sticks on Arnold Avenue same um on point
same side as Uncle Vinnie's really Prime
Steak good you got to make reserve it
Joey
please tell me you've been to um
Chef volis no have you ever heard of it
yes where is it tell me where it is it's
a block away from the Tropicana this
this oh yeah
Sinatra used to eat there I know it's
mentioned in broadwalk Empire you go
downstairs you feel like you're in your
grandmother's basement the food is
arguably the best Italian food in Jersey
because the whole experience that's what
I heard I heard Jay-Z eats there our
[__] Beyonce everything just call and
ask for Mike Esposito tell them who you
are you'll get right in no
I just tell them I like to come down
there and eat it just seems [__] if
you can't get in you got to know
somebody Mike Esposito yeah done trust
me I love you Vic I love you too
much yeah please but now you're here
exactly give me a number before I leave
absolutely I love you [__] I
want to thank Vic for coming on and all
you [__] for watching on a
beautiful Wednesday morning afternoon
whatever stay black and we'll see you
Monday morning Tip Top Magoo [__] sucked
as a now for a word for my [__]
sponsors Jack
all right I want to thank you [__]
suckers and I want to thank Uncle Vic
for watching for being on the show today
the joint is brought to you by this
plate looka you want to fill that hole
in your wall I got the perfect [__]
answer this plate is a cool new metal
poster that you'll want in every room
it's easy to hang up and they got
millions of designs available gaming old
movies new movies comics and they got
Star Wars and Netflix and many more
listen they sent me to Bruce Lee one
[__] tremendous you can hang it in 10
seconds you don't need no tools no
drills no [__] measuring pogo sticks
nothing just do me a favor every time
you buy one display plants a tree in
your name so click the link in the
description to see some of my favorite
displays and save up to 29 get 25 off
when you buy one or two and get 29 off
when you buy three or more that's a
tremendous discount and they'll
automatically be applied to your cart
when you use code Joey when you visit
display.com again that's displayed dis
p-l-a-d-e.com
code Joey j-o-e-y the joint is also
brought to you by
giraffe Kings oh [__] we got some good
games this weekend and you're sitting
there again oh listen if you think
you're gonna download the DraftKings app
because you're gonna [__] better team
you know what the best thing about
DraftKings is
like Monday night the Giants lost do you
think I lost any sleep no because I had
[__] Buckley to score a touchdown and
he scored it and it paid double than
what I invested so there you go and you
want bigger payouts and you got to go
with the [__] same game parlay the
more legs you add the more getas you win
not to mention it's baseball playoffs
World Series UFC come on guys download
the DraftKings Sportsbook app today use
promo code Joey get 203 bets if your
team wins when you place the bet for
five dollars and that's just the start
that you're bankrolling and then we'll
get on those prop bets and we'll do all
that [__] that's code Joey at DraftKings
Sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the NFL minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details now download the
DraftKings app and let's win some
[__] cash please and the joint is
also brought to you by by one of my
[__] favorites liquid IV holy [__]
fuel your play with liquid IV the
hydration is two times faster than water
alone because Life's a lot better when
you're hydrated you get dizzy you get
headaches liquid IV has 10 refreshing
flavors concord grape lemon lime and
tropical punch I like the [__] cherry
and the acai let me tell you something
if you're smoking dope this [__]
will [__] kill that thirst here wake
up eating edible at night you wake up
dizzy and [__] your breath smells like
dick drink a liquid IV and your bad [__]
suckers now do me a favor you can grab
liquid IV in bulk nationwide at Costco
or you get 15 off when you go to liquid
ib.com use promo code Joey at checkout
and I'm Gonna Get You 15 off anything
you order when you shop for better
hydration using promo code Joey at
liquid IV I want to thank this plate I
want to thank liquid IV I want to thank
DraftKings I want to thank all you
[__] Savages better help I don't know
manscape expressvpn I love you I want to
thank Vic I want to thank Mike but I
want to thank you [__] and I'll
see you all next week Tip Top Magoo
ready to go be no it'll be October so
get your [__] together love you stay
black
[Music]
foreign